this particular one they need to do this
more often
um you know I I like the fact that house
I like the production I like how it was
phrased I like how they used the picture
they promoted it was putting the the
date under it and like using it to go
from one like transitioning from one to
another like it's just like look like
whoever did this like yeah let's like
caucus or maybe incorrect if they said
Outsource whoever is responsible you did
a good job keep using them continue
and it's just you know nothing against
you know the marketing and like Major
Nelson in them which is but I feel like
this is going to
get attention more of the people that's
actually watching because I felt like
the old thing was trying to go towards
people that doesn't really gain because
it's cringe-worthy you know they spent
too long on certain subjects but I feel
like this particular one
you're gonna get some people to watch
these